hello everyone and welcome to age of
kaiser now the countdown is over
and even though a lot of you didn't know
what the countdown was about
it was uh actually about the publishing
of chapter one
of age of kaiser it's a project we've
been working on for
i would say about a year and a half uh
when we first
started even discussing such a thing now
to tell you what age of kaiser is it
would
be best if i just told you a very short
history of how it came to be in a few
sentences
so uh some year and a half ago i was
talking to my friend he was
uh waitressing uh waitering at the
restaurant uh about uh about this idea
he was constantly drawing something
constantly doodling something and he was
a big fan of
uh reading reading manga and i told him
is there such a thing as a chess manga
do you know and he didn't know of such a
thing and we tried googling and we've
seen some
concepts we've seen some ideas but
we didn't find anything concise now at
this moment in 2020 when we're
publishing chapter chapter one there are
a few chess mangas already
uh but uh you know the more the merrier
i always say
uh so uh the point uh behind it all is
to promote
chess so that's uh only good if there
are more of them
now i asked him if he would be
interested in maybe starting a project
who knows uh
we could uh you know create a world
create our own characters
uh and uh you know find another way of
how to
how to properly promote chess in a way
that a younger
audience would find it interesting in a
way that more more girls would go
get into chess in a way that it would be
something that
uh like it it wouldn't be just a story
where people would
just you know sit and play chess it
would be an interesting story all in
itself
and chess would gradually creep into the
story and
uh you know in the end uh who knows what
might happen
uh but basically we decided uh okay
we're gonna go for it so how do we go
for it so uh we've decided on a set of
rules uh how we want
the the world to look like what will be
the the rules of this
world that we're going to describe uh
what what the characters will be
and we decided okay so basically you
will
be able to to create all of that the the
art and everything needed for it but we
need a writer
so some year ago we decided uh all right
i'm gonna announce on my channel that we
are looking for a writer for the manga
and uh and i'm saying manga constantly
because uh my friend was uh
into reading manga at the time uh
although since
it's not coming from japan it's
basically a comic or or a
web series or whatever you want to call
it but you get the idea what i'm talking
about so we said we need a writer
and i announced it on the channel and i
received about
500 applications from you guys uh
and it was uh it was a really
troublesome going through it all uh
reading all of them
uh because a lot of you sent uh some of
your own work some of you sent a lot of
your own work and we we had to come
through all of them
uh and in the end we decided uh on a
rider
took us quite some time to go through it
all
and we decided on a mystery man named
abi
and he sent us some of his uh you know
previous work some of his
ideas of how the manga should should
look like
and we said okay so we're gonna go with
uh with
your suggestions uh let's create a
chapter one and see how it looks like
and he he he wrote it that we discussed
uh you know some things about it that we
didn't
micromanage too much we just wanted it
to you know flow as
as uh you know smoothly as possible
and then we had a team we had a we had
uh
uh an artist we had uh we had a writer
and you know the the project uh
started basically and uh we already uh
we already have chapter one chapter two
chapter three chapter four written
and the chapter one is now officially
completed and ready for publishing uh
which will of course be available today
uh
but then we picked up another gentleman
along the way
uh called adam also known as dr
genesis very very mysterious person and
uh
he added something extra to the to the
whole idea he added uh
you know his imagination he he made the
uh the entire thing pop how to say like
uh
um uh he he it was good he just made it
the
the way we actually wanted it to be so
he he became a
uh a very valuable part of the team uh
and uh
basically what he did for chapter one
was only
only processing but uh in other chapters
we will of course uh
be very glad to have him on board as he
has some really really awesome ideas
so that's uh regarding the the short
history of of this project
and now there are well i say three
because i'm mostly over overseeing
everything
and you know just uh making sure that
nothing
uh goes in in the wrong way but uh the
my idea when i
uh started the project was that i just
want uh the world to have uh
uh something really really good
regarding the the characters regarding
the story
and i wanted it to be something that
also promotes chess
in a proper way and i didn't want to get
involved like
if if the artist does that i'm not gonna
i didn't want to be like no dude this
instead like if you want to do it that
way do it that way and the the same way
it was with the writer and with uh
with adam in in the past processing uh
stage of the
uh of the creation of chapter one and uh
this is basically the result so that's a
little bit about the history behind it i
could
talk a lot more about it but i i was
planning on making this video short now
uh what
the goal of this project is the goal is
to promote
chess even further on a new front like i
said when we were starting there
pretty much wasn't anything uh in
in this way related to chess like in the
manga world in the comics were like
maybe it was but
it was very difficult to uh come
upon it like just you know a quick
search wouldn't really really drop
anything
uh but yeah that was basically the goal
for me and i thought that the the world
should have this and we like we we could
try make something
like that and maybe it works so why not
try it
now regarding the cost of actually
reading the manga when you click on the
link in the description below
it will ask you for your credit card
details and you will have to pay 100
to read the first chapter that of course
is a joke uh
that would be silly uh no the uh the
manga will be completely free
you can read it online on uh the uh
newly published website which is
agonator.com
also will be published today at uh 20
p.m central european time
uh you can read it uh on the website you
can download the pdf for free you can
share it with your friends at the bar in
the library also for free
and if you enjoy it and only if you
enjoy it
you are welcome to support their work uh
and you will be able to
like leave a one-time contribution uh
where you will be publicly thanked on
the website and you will of course
gain bragging rights uh towards your
friends
now uh that being said uh the link is in
the description
so when you click on it you will go
immediately to the
manga page of the agarmatter.com website
where you will be able to
click on it read it and enjoy it now
other than the manga
itself the website has some other
features but we're gonna
talk about that in a separate video now
regarding the manga there's uh
some additional content that i would
really recommend you read because it's
uh it's really great now chapter one
there's only
only so much you can fit in the actual
chapter of the manga
so what we did uh for uh for additional
reading and
additional enjoying uh if i do say so
uh is that we've added short stories uh
that you will be able to read
on the website uh also just click on the
link you you will see everything it's
very very natural to click
uh there's a there's a file where you
will be able to read a bit more about
all of us even though for now uh the
team is still
still has decided to be anonymous but
at some point we will make a video after
the situation in the world has you know
quieted down that we can all
get together and make a video where you
will be introduced to everyone involved
and i don't know it's uh i think it's
really a great team i
i think uh the the energy between them
is great and they
are uh well that they have created
something great and that it could
become uh much much greater in the
future but for now i don't know
just uh i really want you to check it
out just uh read it uh
read the chapter one we've published
read the additional stories the stories
are amazing they have a lot of
background they have
additional art on the website which you
can also enjoy
so basically in short uh i don't know uh
just uh
to give you uh an example of what it is
uh the way our
writer abby put it uh the the
the whole thing is set in a
post-apocalyptic dystopian age where the
world is
ruled by chess playing robots now this
uh sounds
uh the way it sounds but it's not uh
really like that
uh for now it might be in the future but
you know just uh
don't think it's like that's what you're
going to see like i said i didn't want
to create something where
you know you open the first page and
people are you know playing chess you
open the second page people are playing
chess i want to have
great characters a great world design
great everything and that
then the chest slowly creeps in and
uh well i don't want to spoil too much
but basically we're going to go in that
direction
and how he put it i'm sure anyone with
any interest in chess or artificial
intelligence philosophy of the mind
computability
graphic novels or hard sci-fi will find
this to be
an enjoyable read so there you have it
that's
all i'm going to mention in this video
as i really don't want to spoil too much
but i wanted to
kind of give you an idea of what this is
and what we're trying to accomplish with
it so
um basically he he said it all with the
sentence i i have really nothing to add
here
if you enjoy such such topics if you
enjoy chess i'm sure you're going to
enjoy age of kaiser
so read the manga read chapter one read
the the additional stories
uh you know try try to get involved with
with the lore as it's still being built
you know
who knows where we're going to end up
and i'm incredibly interested we are all
incredibly interested in your
uh feedback so what do you think about
everything like
you know don't be uh don't be
you know don't pull back on the critics
we want as as many
as much critics as you can possibly
muster up so
for now you can uh comment on this video
but in the future we will have a
separate place on the website where you
will also be able to comment where you
will be able to
have some suggestions for us and uh in
some way maybe even get involved
in the in the creation of this world so
now like i said uh for now just uh do
that uh if you enjoy it do consider
supporting us
and um for now there's only one way you
can support it via one-time contribution
but in the future we will have some
other
other means of of uh support uh such as
patreon such as merchandise such as
uh actually getting involved in the
manga itself uh such as
buying the the physical copy for now we
only have the
digital copy but very soon we will start
the
uh the uh to create the the actual
physical copy of
chapter one but i will keep you informed
because there's a
lot to allow to do here but for now all
you need to do is
read it it's free share it with everyone
and let us know what you think
so that's uh that's the news i hope you
enjoyed it
and i will see you soon uh have a good
read